pour continuer à parler du niger a les
élections présidentielles et
législatives qui ont lieu dimanche
merci aussi à auxerre 2 d'être à nouveau
avec nous parmi les grands favoris
mohamed bazoum le candidat du parti
présidentiel le pnds le parti nigérien
pour la démocratie et le socialisme
quels sont les autres favoris et quelles
sont leurs chances
un douar de base on vous avez le
candidat du père l'ancien ministre de
l'intérieur tout âge à qui se trouve
être albadé abouba
vous avez aussi le candidat mano
semaines qui viennent d'avoir un soutien
de taille celui de l'ancien premier
ministre hama amadou gon la candidature
a été rejetée par la professionnelle
donc assez ouvert ce sont des élections
qui sont ouvertes et probablement il y
aura un second tour contre eux à ce que
dit cet analyste
et est ce qui est des risques
d'embrasement dans les rues à l'annoncé
des résultats ce qui est des risques de
fraude
oui les risques de fraude puisque comme
vous le savez même à l'issue des
élections locales
on a constaté de poste de france et le
carré le parti le principal parti au
pouvoir le ps arrive en tête avec plus
de mille et quelques un délégué donc les
opposants on dit que produit des preuves
de fraudes dans certaines localités
donc nous pensons que et il peut y avoir
de ford mais il ne faudrait pas qu'il y
ait une
et comme le disent ou chaos ou leucan le
principal candidat et c'est la ligue 2
le premier tour c'est aussi le défi
sécuritaire en sept soldats nigériens
tués en début de semaine
le climat est toujours tendue avec un
impact sur la tenue des élections
écoutez nous sommes pliés les tours vous
le savez de la frontière libyenne en
passant par celle du bassin du lac tchad
et la zone des trois frontières
le mali le burkina et le niger ne sont
pris en étau et il ya certaines zones
qui sont sous état d'urgence et le
gouvernement a pris des mesures pour que
ces élections se passent bien et nous
espérons qu'il y est pas beau de
problèmes notamment sur le problème
sécuritaire pour ne pas que ces
élections soient attachés et
d'irrégularités et justement par rapport
aux défis sécuritaires qu'ils seront les
marges de manoeuvre du futur président
oui c'est continuer s'est continuée
effectivement à travailler avec ses
collègues de du g5 sahel nous et aussi
avoir ses partenaires les vacances aussi
les autres partenaires les états unis et
les autres pays qui aident les pays du
sahel à s'en sortir
aida ce bourbier touristes merci moussa
aksar d'avoir répondu à nos questions je
rappelle que vous êtes journaliste
d'investigation nigeria un consultant
international en ce qui concerne les
questions de sécurité au sahel merci
beaucoup d'avoir répondu à nos questions
et très bonnes fêtes de fin d'année à
vous